the second evaluation Criterion I want
to talk about are your team abilities so
what exactly does this mean to you
abilities well this is how well you
contribute to the overall success of a
team you know one question always is to
what extent to really contribute to a
positive and inclusive atmosphere in the
team room sometimes things can be tough
your team might struggle with a
difficult client maybe you need to work
late for several days in a row and all
these things can really take a toll on
team Mori are you than the person who
always complains adds to all this
negativity draws everybody down or a
user person who despite difficult
circumstances is able to increase the T
Mori to contribute to create and add to
our overall positive atmosphere